soldaten des österreichischen
bundesheeres sprengten am dienstag eine
100 jahre alte eisenbahnbrücke über den
milchfluss zwischen ruprechtshofen und
sankt leonhard in niederösterreich
aufgrund der knapp 44 tonnen schweren
stahl fachwerkkonstruktion und der
bahndämme kann bei hochwasser der fluss
nur schwer abfließen
bei flut sind die angrenzenden
siedlungsgebiete in ruprechtshofen und
im melt welt bedroht daher entschloss
man sich für die sprengung der brücke
wir haben eine gute halbe
dreiviertelstunde zeit in aller ruhe
noch mal alles durch zu gehen für die
für die sprengung alles vorzubereiten
und und er die ganzen absperrmaßnahmen
zu treffen so dass wirklich nichts
geschehen kann
ausgelöst wurde die sprengung durch ein
elektronisches pionier funk fern
zinssystem danach löste ein bergepanzer
die verkeilten brücken teile und ließ
diese in den fluss stürzen
anschließend waren die angehörigen des
pionierbataillons drei aus melk mit dem
ausheben der brücken reste beschäftigt
die brücke war durch gesprengt an fast
allen stellen bis bis auf dieser zehn
zentimeter durch das könnten konnte sie
sich nicht denen hat sich wieder in sich
selbst verteilt und wir haben dann denn
den zwang mit einem pionierpanzer
herausgenommen den wir die brücke
gegenwert der fluss richtung gezogen
haben und somit ist sie dann herunter
gefallen aus dem 2